the point about points
is that
our idea of points like when we go like
this we go here's my point 3.5 i'm going
to move it over here here's 3.5 right
that's wrong
that's not 3.5 if that was really 3.5 we
wouldn't be able to see a thing
a point is not
a small tiny circle that's just a
representation and what it does is it
gives us the wrong sense of how things
are like if you remove a point okay and
it was in your mind of a ruler you
should be able to like hold it up to the
sun and see a little bit of sunlight
shine through
but that's wrong it's impossible because
if that was the case we'd be removing a
little bit of length and then we
wouldn't have one
so this is pushing our notions of
what maths is which is why i love it
i love this stuff
but your whole premise your discussion
here is how do we measure numbers yeah
who wants to measure numbers who said
numbers were measurable in the first
place where why is this a why is this a
problem for you like why is this a
problem you don't measure numbers no why
is this a problem
measuring with why is this a problem
because
we are we are using stuff that we
haven't proved we're using naive notions
of measure
that's why that's a problem we're making
assumptions
this almost broke maths where i'm going
with this it almost broke maths
and that sounds like i'm being really
full on but it's absolutely true and i
don't know if i'm going to be able to
show you every the exact reason why it
almost broke mats
but what i'm talking about here i can i
can tell you right now what this led to
this led to the computer what i'm
talking about
but the hair's standing up on the back
of my neck when i talk about this that's
how exciting this is it's so exciting
that people started going oh i know how
to measure you take one you take the
final take the initial sure that's all
right well what happens when you remove
points what happens when you remove an
infinite number of points let's just
think about it like this okay let's go
from 0 to 12
okay so the length of that is 12. so 12
take 0 is 12. that's the length yep so
then i'm going to wrap it around a clock
face oops it's not a very good clock
it's more like an egg so there's 12
there nine okay
and the reason why i want to show you
this is because now i'm going to mark
out every fraction so it's almost like
every
single way that you could divide up time
in a way that would be sensible
i'm actually going to put holes
tiny little holes
all around the clock face
now this is where i'm hopefully going to
break your brain because now i've
removed every single fraction
and a segment of a number line and the
fact that i've made it 12 doesn't matter
what's the length
of this line now remember the real
number line contains numbers other than
fractions
because
most the real number line are
transcendental numbers what's kind of
crazy is is that in this case though
between any two fractions right
so between any two fractions so let's
just say here between um
between zero and one
right
between zero and one you have moved half
yeah but you've also removed
a quarter and an eighth and a sixteenth
and a thirty two rubber right keeps
going
all the way down
so between any two fractions there's
another fraction in between any two
fractions there's another fraction so
the in math they call it dense it's
dense with numbers
so it does should make you feel a little
bit uneasy
that you might be making a mistake
what we can play with is how many points
there are so what you can do
is you can you can kind of count out all
the
all the numbers right this is a fraction
here so you could go it's this on this
whatever it is so that's two on one um
this is two on two this is two and three
this is two on four et cetera et cetera
so each point each point represents a
fraction
and you've kind of covered every single
possible fraction that there is right
and what we're trying to do is we're
trying to show that this all the
fractions are countable or listable so
this is a really great thing and what
you do is you draw the snake so you draw
the snake like so and you do it like
that okay and you're basically going i
can create a list of all the fractions
if we know that we can list all these
points
okay
let's make a list of them so let's talk
about all the fractions let's call it f
all the fractions between 0 and 12. so
you know they'll be a half will be in
there you know uh
two-thirds will be in there four-thirds
will be in there whatever if that's
listable
let's measure the length of all of them
so the length what's the length of half
well that's zero what's the length of
two thirds well that's zero what's the
length of four thirds or that's zero
so i've got an infinite sum of zero
so zero added to itself infinitely many
times
0.
so it's because of the the number
in a sense the number
even though it's infinite an infinite
really isn't a number but the fact that
the type of infinite it is
a countable infinite and it's listable
means that if we remove a countable
number of points a listable number of
points
we haven't changed the length because
the length of all those points have to
be zero if i remove your feelings yeah
your size won't change
just like if i remove the numbers the
infinitely small abstract numbers from a
line the length of the line doesn't
change
numbers don't have volume or size
so they because they're just an abstract
thing they're a describing word
is this is this what are we starting to
come towards philosophy here no i'm just
i'm a bit weirded out by you removing my
feelings without my feelings i can't do
maths
i uh because it's all it's all very
emotional
i
see this is this is the thing is that
you're creating you're putting a nice
analogy on something when this is
already an analogy the problem is is
that humans and mathematicians
we are really analogizing even the math
that you see is in a sense it's an
analogy just like how roman numbers
was like they thought they had it they
thought yeah we know numbers they're
never going to change we're in charge
they're never going to change and
they've changed
and it's because there's been a better
way to represent numbers
and i think what i love about this is
that we draw a line well first of all
you can't draw a line it's impossible
it's just a very very thin rectangle and
you draw points that's ridiculous you
can't draw points but there you go we
draw points
and then suddenly we go oh i know what
to do there because you know i
i know how to use a ruler you do final
take initial fantastic ah suddenly
something makes sense in maths
it doesn't make sense
suddenly you're confronted with these
these conundrums of like what happens
when i take away a point
well nothing because
there is no next point like there is no
hole per se
and so when you try and thinking about
it when you try thinking about it you
actually have to start questioning every
single assumption and this is where
this led into an analysis of set theory
what assumptions
were mathematicians making about maths
very heavy questions what mathematicians
were able to do
should i go here
okay i'll go there
what mathematicians were able to do
were able to
create sets of numbers
that you couldn't measure
and it was it was linked to these kinds
of ideas so you're actually
picking all the the guy who did it was a
guy called giuseppe vitale
and he came up with this idea of
consider the solid segment between zero
and one and consider all the fractions
but then he kind of considered every
single copy of that
in
zero to one and what that means is very
complicated it's called a partition but
basically he found all these different
copies of it then he just took one point
from every single copy
and that set
you could not measure there was no way
that you could get a sensible answer
getting zero is a sensible answer this
gave no sensible answer it gave a
contradiction you look at it one way you
get one answer you look at the other way
you get a different answer that's a
problem
because
i thought i knew how to measure i
thought i knew how to use a ruler i
thought i knew maths
and this guy realized that there were
these
sets that you couldn't measure
and that caused
massive problems mathematicians were
very very upset the thing that i
realized
when i when i studied this is that it
made me question what i knew about
numbers so my life i see as a timeline
of discovery of numbers
why not you know i discovered numbers
the way watching sesame street or
whatever you do and you get a sense of
oh yeah one two fractions you start
getting your head around these things
but suddenly when you come to the point
where
you think about how numbers are related
and points and
decimal expansions all that sort of
stuff you start going wow
three is weird like i thought i knew
three
but three is very strange the
abstraction of these numbers are very
strange and what it really drove me to
is to question everything you have to
question everything in maths there's so
much that we bring in from the outside
world
which
just
gives you the wrong idea we thought we
we knew measure because measurement was
about numbers
so a ruler
you know you could go there's a ruler
there's a real ruler there's a
mathematical ruler it looks like a ruler
surely i can't go wrong with this
but what you can do the sorts of sets
that you can make the kind of removal of
points
you're really doing things there's no
way you could do in reality no way at
all you could do in reality
so
yeah so this is the stuff and then
exploring these things
that's what really gets i mean like
people actually started to question
reasoning
out of this how we reason
and
and it actually did lead to the computer
i could actually led alan shearing was
the guy who was trying to reformulate
some of the questions that came out of
this he started reformulating kurt
goudel's work
and out of that
came the turing machine which is
for all intents and purposes the first
computer might not be exactly but anyway
he's the guy who kind of came up with it
and they were just trying to think they
were trying to go how do you think like
what are the assumptions we make
so yeah so for me
this was like the crowning glory of my
mathematical education was
really getting to
the bottom of like you know if i was a
musician it's like what is music like
what is it why does it make you feel a
certain way but it sounds like your
conclusion is we don't know what don't
we know what numbers are
i would love that
because i
i'm assuming
it's going to be completely
incomprehensible to me